20 years of Good Will Hunting yeah it is
crazy and actually I first started
thinking about it when I was in Toronto
because we shot Good Will Hunting there
and I hadn't shot anything I mean I'd
been to the tip a lot you know in the
intervening years but I hadn't worked
you know and shot in Toronto since then
and so to be there I was shooting this
downsizing you know 20 years from the
time that I can shooting it well I think
so it was deeply affecting on a number
of levels because we we've put so much
of ourselves into that movie and of our
kind of creative energy at that in our
20s was kind of all put in the good
wanting and to be there and with the
kind of the bittersweet reality that
Robbins go on and Elliott Smith and at
the same time that you know Ben and I
are going strong 20 years later and have
these careers that we cherish and if
there's just a lot there you know so
it's crazy that it's been 20 years it
went by hard you look young you look
amazing thank you you probably weren't
born when he made good watching so thank
you I feel old
this move is so heartwarming I got to
watch it last night and it's really
fresh in my mind
downsizing is about saving yourself we
live like kings got best houses best
restaurants Cheesecake Factory got three
of them it makes you think about all the
little things that important in life and
I have two kids at home you have four at
home
what are those precious moments that you
keep near to your heart oh man they're
there luckily they're too numerous to
count you know every day there seems to
be you know you know more of them and
you know it when your kids are young
they're just changing so rapidly and you
know just trying to be present to kind
of soak it all in it's the coloring with
them is there anything in particular
that you keep with you well I do we went
out to eat a couple nights ago and I
actually caught myself because they gave
us you know the adult menu and the kids
menu and and at one point my wife look
up and goes are you coloring and I was
like really seriously coloring yeah
oh so keV whining you know get the get
the lines perfect so sometimes you think
we're in the normal world something
happens
oh my god you realize we're not the
other thing with this movie is it's
being able to adapt to change and be
able to move around so it begs the
question if you were to move into a new
community you could have a neighbor
would it be Jimmy Kimmel or would it be
George Clooney just the season Jimmy
Kimmel you had such a great year
together forgive that man for anything
top three things about Jimmy Kimmel that
you loved or you hate this year watching
him completely ruined the Oscars that
was that was great that was enjoyable
those are all three of my you even did
list kid I think as a Manny on his on
his show read George Clooney right well
I did I did I was Manning for George for
a little while George you know was in
town so I and I was unemployed so I I
managed for him what it's a nanny who's
a man she showed me his photos of his
kids on his phone oh yeah this was in
August but I mean you guys don't get to
see each other fairly often but when you
do have you seen him in that zone as a
father yeah oh no he's great and I knew
he'd be great yeah you know I think I
think you know someone like him takes
pride in like being a really good diaper
changer because you know you don't want
anybody saying you're not and yeah but
he's so kind of centered and happy now
and I'm just thrilled for him if he
deserves it